I team listen up this crew is about
family but the game has changed now
[Music]
Dominic Toretto just went rogue you're
gonna turn your back on family I know it
looks bad don't give up on I'm so easy
you've only got one chance to make this
family whole again
don't do this dawn you ready one thing I
can guarantee no one's ready for this
she's the very definition of AI tech
terrorism there's thousands of cars in
the city and now they're all mine
now I know what it feels like to be
every cop ever chasing us
[Music]
wait-wait-wait
Oh
Londyn Abu Dhabi Cuba our paths have
crossed before dawn you just didn't know
it I think I need to remind you why you
chose to be here I got no choice if you
gotta catch Dom you got any little help
if you want to tell me why you just put
me in a room with this team crumpets
eatin criminal you don't think that
tight t-shirts cutting off the
circulation he'll Brian you should get
bigger slice you guys are gonna work
together love to have been waiting for
this we got a tank now matzo whoa baby
[Music]
they just don't give up either he
thought this was gonna be a street fight
I gotta talk right now take the wheel
what
this is crazy alright you get style
points for that one I don't know why
you're doing this but I know one thing
you love me
[Music]
fire on your ass
[Music]
I'm taking you down so write out where I
got if you gotta catch Dom you're gonna
need a little help